sherry told me she had the pot in her  hand okay but that's alright she's  probably near where you going  the space is freaking me just hold on a  second please just there's there's  something to this when you just seduced  humor people just talk about it too much  I got the guy's bail receipt excuse me  excuse me  why this can't be right it is how do you  know who checked was it about the  cashier's check for $200,000 huh you  paid that I don't what do you think what  do I think this I think that guy is a  friend with deep pockets that's very  deep very deep I think that guys getting  a [ __ ] he's still eating so it's hard  to tell they're gonna have those do I  get one what who could get that much  cash together that quickly what's that  for why have you ever tried it I can't  say that I have all right well you take  this one I'll take the other  what are we in the sixth grade I'm not  gonna eat this